今天想跟大家聊一個我覺得很有趣的案例，跟投資有關，但又很不一樣。Odin這家公司，他們做的事情其實是把過去高門檻的「創投」業務，變成一種人人都能參與的平台。
創投？那不是有錢人跟專業機構才玩的嗎？感覺這個門檻很高，一般人根本沾不上邊，怎麼可能人人參與？聽起來有點天方夜譚。
我一開始也覺得有點出乎意料，但它厲害的地方就在於，Odin把創投的流程「平台化」跟「模組化」。就像原文裡講的，他們被稱為「創投界的Shopify」。
Shopify是讓大家能輕鬆開網店嘛，所以Odin就是讓大家能輕鬆開創投公司？這怎麼做到？法律、會計、盡職調查這些專業，光想就覺得很複雜。
對，它就是把那些複雜的環節都包起來了。Odin的共同創辦人Patrick Ryan說，他們能處理從「法律架構」、「投資人入駐」到「了解你的客戶（KYC）/反洗錢（AML）」、還有「支付和報告」這些事。等於說，這些一般人難以跨越的專業門檻，他們都幫你解決了。
哇，那這樣成本會不會很高？畢竟這些專業服務本身就不便宜。還有，這種平台化之後，投資品質怎麼維持？總不能隨便一個人都能當基金管理人吧？
其實原文沒有提到具體費用，不過他們主要就是讓任何人都能「發起」和「管理」自己的私募基金。這點很重要，讓那些本來沒有資源的個人或小型機構，有了機會進入這個市場。
聽起來是把專業服務拆解成積木，讓大家組裝。那這個模式撐得久嗎？那些傳統的創投基金，優勢就是專業背景、人脈跟資源，Odin怎麼跟他們競爭？
它不是去取代傳統創投，而是創造一個新的市場，原文有提到，Odin正在賦能「新一代的基金經理人」、「天使投資聯盟」和「創業者」去投資公司。它讓更多人有能力進入這個遊戲。
也就是說，如果我是個小公司老闆，可能我本身生意做得不錯，有點閒錢想投資，或是想投資我的上下游夥伴，我就可以透過Odin自己成立一個小基金？
對，就是這個意思。它提供了一個「原來投資可以這樣做」的實際路徑。對於像台灣很多渴望進入新創投資，但可能缺乏專業資源的個人、家族辦公室或中小型企業來說，這簡直是打開了一扇窗。
那從這個案例，如果我是創業者或公司主管，可以學到什麼？把高門檻服務拆解並大眾化，這個思路應用在我的事業上，有什麼啟發嗎？
我猜啦，就是看看自己行業裡，有沒有哪些服務也是門檻很高，但其實可以被「平台化」或「模組化」的。比如說，原本只有專業會計師才能做的報稅，是不是也能有個「報稅界的Shopify」？
嗯，這倒也是。很多專業服務其實都有機會簡化。那一般上班族呢？這個概念怎麼帶入工作或生活？
我覺得是學習「化繁為簡」的思維。例如你可能覺得某個任務很複雜、很專業，只有少數人能做。但你可以想想，這個任務能不能拆解成幾個步驟？每個步驟有沒有現成的工具可以輔助？
或是說，把一些原本很耗時的流程，像寫報告、排行程，透過工具或標準化流程，變成只要點幾下滑鼠就能完成。
對。就像Patrick Ryan從消費品和企業創投的經驗，看到傳統投資系統的不必要複雜性，才有了Odin的靈感。其實我們身邊的工作，說不定也有類似的「不必要複雜性」可以被簡化。
的確，就像Odin今年在歐洲，已經促成了將近10億歐元的創投工具公告，這數字還蠻驚人的。它確實讓更多人能透過資本配置來影響未來。
沒錯，這個做法很有意思，好像也提醒了我們，很多看似遙不可及的專業，說不定只要換個角度，就能找到讓它更普及的機會。